[Musique]
dans la vie rien n'arrive par hasard
réfléchissez à cette théorie un moment
[Musique]
toutes vos initiatives personnelles
professionnelles
charlene je devais absolument être
disposé à faire des choix qui seront
difficiles à vous comporter de façon
ignoble mais aussi à risque et vos biens
les plus dîner steam abl parce que tout
ce qui a de la valeur ne sera jamais
obtenue sans faire des sacrifices
ce sera
this way
maintenant que votre objectif est plus
concrète
[Musique]
pensez vous toujours qu'il y a des
limites à ne pas franchir pour défendre
une course
dans notre cas ce serait une nuit seul
avec votre mari cela constituerait une
position acceptable pour une offre ferme
de financement de votre entreprise
tu sais quoi exactement sur un an gomery
les choses pourraient devenir
extrêmement dangereuse
les choses ont toujours été dangereuse
ça
tu voudras d'imaginer qu'il y aurait ce
don fait je suis consciente d'avoir
commis une erreur je mérite pas de
perdre tout ce que j'ai tout ce que je
regrette c'est d'avoir eu le malheur de
croiser votre chemin
et combien de gens vont devoir souffrir
pour que vous arriviez à vos fins vous
avez suivi votre intuition sans penser
que vous vous impliquerez longtemps
non pire des victimes qui soit et c'est
elle qui choisit d'en faire une autre à
son tour je me suis victime de personne
[Musique]
etes-vous absolument certaine que c'est
le choix que vous voulez faire je ne
suis pas celle que vous pourriez pas
encore je commence à avoir du potentiel
en
[Musique]
réussir à n'importe quel prix
nous émeut
[Musique]
e